as much as i don't like gary vaynerchuk
and i'm certain that he's going to die
young because he doesn't sleep enough
he uh which like tell me that's not the
truth by the way no he he looks so tired
like he's just
constantly in terms of comprehending a
trillion compared to a million
a million seconds is 11 days a trillion
seconds is 36 000
years what's your thoughts on people's
criticisms about bezos becoming the
first trillionaire
i mean that well as we've just discussed
is
mental sans one achilles since the last
time that you spoke
yeah i made a meal of it i think you
would say by way of scaling the what
happened question
i can just say it once and then link
people to this podcast
so ladies and gentlemen welcome back
i'm joined by joni and yousef from
propanefitness.com
do you ever say ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls uh no because this is an
adult show for adult people
but we're also joined by the explicit
rate yeah of course it is
that's the number one reason not having
the explicit rating correct is the
number one reason shows get taken down
off the
apple podcast store wow
just accidentally slip in a c-bomb or
something and then yeah that's it oh
this is made for children
um johnny's brought his dog johnny can
we see your dog can we see dexter
look at you all black features
yeah he can't see his face until he's
looking to the side and then you're like
all right that's a
[Music]
[Laughter]
one achilles since the last time that
you spoke yeah yeah
which is a big event it's a it was
it was uh impressive yeah
i made a i made a meal of it i think you
would say it's impressive how you felt
at the time i imagine not
no you're like lying on the ground going
fair enough i wasn't getting
full cricket whites yeah
so i might as well by way of scaling
what happened the what happened question
i can just say it once and then link
people to this podcast
so nice i decided to start playing
qriket again
after 12 years of absence
um went and netted a local team got
picked played last
weekend um went into bat and
was playing pretty well 20 not out
couple of boundaries
only one only one chance that uh that i
gave away pretty difficult it was all
right
set off for a run pushed off with my
right foot and um
just felt like i'd been shot in the back
of the leg but no pain which was like
pretty weird uh set off left foot fine
then went to put my right foot down and
it was just like stepping on
like a wobble board basically couldn't
support my weight thought
i think i've snapped my achilles then
hit the deck
then the bastards that i was playing
against ran me out
so as i was on the floor with the
snapped achilles they decided to run me
out as opposed to just leaving me
which i was like come on mate
i don't miss it i could have lost a lot
of blood here uh
missing an achilles here um then
ended up at the rvi dad took me to the
rvi um
like the lack of pain was kind of quite
weird could you walk
walk off though or do you have to get
like do you get stretch it off
um like to um you know like arm around
either
it's not like an on an on hand doctor or
physio or something there no the only
the closest doctor was
dr youssef smith the sconie the
left scob yeah um dr scott
i have a question hit
[Laughter]
what's the sensation of being shot
without the pain
so like a maybe more accurate would be
like if someone took a baseball bat to
the back of your
leg so it's like a jolt it's like a
percussion
absolutely impact yeah sensation of
impact
yeah because it is like you hear
anything no but i was everyone was
shouting at the same time because as you
hit a run you have to call to the other
player
yes exactly um i'm pretty certain
that it usually makes a a fairly big
crack when it happens
um you can hang a car off it
odd my favorite thing about the whole
episode is
is turning up to hospital and just
seeing someone in full cricket wise and
thinking oh that's not chris
and that is slowly oh here we go but
that was the thing like
if you play pretty much any other spot
tennis football you turn up and you're
in shorts
it's kind of easy it's at least slightly
inconspicuous
maybe he just dresses like that but like
full
full cricket whites um which were brand
new because
my old ones were from when i was like 20
years old so i had to get
cut out of the cricket whites once i had
the boot on
i had to get cut out of a brand new set
of socks
to get to my foot because my foot had
swollen up it's a big
big elephant foot it's a fat foot yeah
very boggy
um how's the buggy uh so yeah just went
in
um a a lady looked at me and went oh
uh you've it's gone that's
and that was it um i was cinnamon from
there on they put me in a boot
and i sent me home so if you squeeze
where your achilles
tendon should be yeah do you just feel
you just
pinch skin how do you describe because
you did that
that's the test so you have someone have
their
their shin flat and you squeeze their
calf
and if the foot goes then the achilles
is attached
and if you squeeze the car from the foot
it's just done
bad news yeah then it's cinnamon um
but yeah so we're gonna have to explain
the cinnamon thing it's just a video so
dean
can you make the here i come i am
cinnamon clip
appear right now please video
video
[Applause]
is it is it not a reference to something
though is that not why the kid shouts it
i feel like he's not just making it up i
think it's a level thing
is it copyrightable to include here i
come i am cinnamon in a podcast
i mean joe rogan does it all the time so
don't care does he say here i come i am
in a podcast i feel like he doesn't i
don't no no
he gets jamie to pull up something it's
just a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] it's a fat
ginger german child running through
him shouting running at someone here i
come i am cinnamon
so yeah was that was it but it's a lack
of pain man like the fact that there was
no pain
and everyone like a lot of people say it
when it happens um one of my buddies
was playing badminton and snapped his
and people didn't
they they didn't take him to the
hospital he had to like convince them
that something had happened because he
was so calm
right like so he'd snapped his achilles
yeah no no
i'm i'm being patricia i'm being serious
um and then no one wanted to listen to
him because he was just
like oh if you've snapped your achilles
you'd be in pain but it
for anyone who's considering snapping an
achilles you're paying peaks at about
four out of ten and i'm pretty sure that
that was because of the angle my foot
was at in the car on the way to the rvi
like other than that it was like three
hours
three years like this video the video of
the car accident
and the guy gets out and goes i'm i'm
uninjured
i'm uninjured and also just extremely
calm like his car
is his car not on its side and he's just
one in the uk
isn't it yeah yeah i'm no anger i'm
uninjured
are you okay what was that video that
went viral last year was it like
jess glenn who's your dad no the one
where
a guy at laurie was driving down the
motorway
oh he did sideswipe that ellie ellie
golden
golden golden yeah and ellie goulding's
there and she's like don't worry
i'll sing us back to health like that's
what she said
no all right okay very much cringiest
thing she could ever say
yeah she rocks up in a big range road
but there's just like this guy
driving down the motorway oh yeah
because he's just being pushed by a
lorry yeah
he's just sat there like and the lorry
can't see because of the
how sheer because it if you're in the
car there'd be initial
fear then anger then just apathy
irritation eventually
when you really didn't believe the lorry
driver because i didn't know
very much like dave benson what's he
called dave benson jennings or something
the one who did
yeah get your own back and dunked people
in the gunge and stuff i didn't know
that's a reference that's a reference
from like 1995 that you've pulled out
there it's the last tv show i've seen
i remember
i think he came to my freshers week that
guy and did like a student version of
get your own back where everyone got
gunged did he yeah
gunks wouldn't be surprised if chris got
him like yeah because
he um saw his new book chris you got the
wheelstone raider didn't you
no we didn't we didn't get one that was
someone else we got gaquan
we got um the beast no
i did so i refused to book the chuckle
brother
like i just thought it was oh yeah it's
so sad
try and tell me that you used to be able
to book the chuckle brothers
and now you book the brother and it's
like it's just
it's just constantly reminding him of
his best mate's death like i don't want
to do that true and like everyone who
goes in the club goes oh well what
happened to barry
oh he's died oh barry yeah and it just
becomes like a
let's get something everyone's been
drinking for all day and then they
end up in this really sad scenario in a
club where
everyone like remembers watching on tv
you know i'll never be the same again
nah not
that's why that's why i didn't want to
do it so
we went we went with gokuan and phil
mitchell from eastenders
oh nice phil mitchell was good fun what
do these people do
when you book the photos mostly gokuan
is a dj and now you'd think um
fashionista guy gay
um asian you would just think it's like
spice girls and wenger boys all night
long you just think it's like
it's like techno it was like really good
house music
like he's a proper dj
um which i was super interesting yeah i
know i know
he's yeah because like if he's not basic
enough to be like
spice girls and banger boys like he's
definitely a
very quite high level guy yeah he's two
orders of
of uh magnitude down from whatever you
thought
so yeah that was it that was it got in
got in hospital um and then there was
some weird stuff so i've been reached
out by like tons and tons of people and
again
this is not the achilles podcast but
just it may happen to you it may happen
to your
like someone that you know and it's
pretty common injury like i've had
four people messaged this week since
saturday
saying that they've ruptured their
achilles um like
they've ruptured it since suspected
since they saw that you yes
and that's two of them are in one was in
sunderland and one was
in the rvi like on tuesday
um so there's this new conservative
management approach which is
what i got yusuf to do uh a literary
review
i tried to get yusuf to do as as a
comprehensive
review of all of the material he could
get from british medical journal
under the table while i was speaking to
the doctor so he's like right mate so do
you fancy uh
should we operate or do you want to go
for conservative management
i'm like jesus can you just check what
is the long-term athletic function
outcomes from it
um i've started active campaigns
so how do i
know um so
long story short at the moment there's a
trial going on to see if they cannot
open people up and they can do it just
by pushing your foot down like a
ballerina toe
and allowing the ends of the tendon to
grow back together naturally
long story short i haven't found many
people that have gone conservative
management and don't have a caveat to
their recovery
so most people have said it's fine but
i have loss of function lots of
sensation lots of mobility
whereas like kobe bryant operated on
david beckham operated on
everyone else that i know that's a
higher end athlete operated on and none
of them have caveats to their
recovery so like there's some risks with
surgery obviously you'll be open wounds
there's like blood thinners that i need
to take for six weeks in case i get a
blood clot
uh like other baby full or is it
local or i know so in the in the side of
the knee
uh numb the whole leg then right local
anaesthetic then
bottle of morphine to take home with me
um
which is hopefully not going to be
needed
but i think if you're given permission
to
to take morphine just having just like
yeah well like you don't you don't go
i don't know that's irresponsible yeah
what do you think like a doctor's told
me to do this
so so i got a message off a guy in
america and he was talking about
how he was using tylenol and one of
those
other like real popular opiates that are
used by
middle-aged women um and
he he it was all these like i had
tylenol every eight hours and this
austrian [ __ ] every four hours
americans love painkillers though yeah
that's different to that's different to
nighthold isn't it yeah
and then i was told well you're going to
get a small bottle of morphine to take
home with you i was like hang on
why is america in the 21st century and
i'm stuck in world war one
like what's going on here but they they
have like an
opiate epidemic or opioid epidemic like
they're using oxygen they're giving
people oxycodone to take home like
that's what you said that was the drug
yeah they're not called different things
in the us because it's like the brand
that they're called
yeah it's like oxycontin or something
but yeah i've had oxycodone after my
ball surgery and it is
very strong
[Music]
have you ever seen david after the
dentist
so many viral video references today but
it's this kid who's come out of the
dentist and he's
um he's like rolling his head around in
the back of the car and like
just [ __ ] talking his dad
it was like that like i was just smack
talking to the nurses
like i would honestly i would pay
i would love to see that but there's so
much i think that would be the funniest
thing
because you just had ball surgery and
you're just being unpleasant to people
listen brav i'll wreck you yeah
i wasn't being aggressive with them i
was um just very delirious
i'm [ __ ] telling you man
you should have a full-time cameraman
probably around because the stuff that
would get captured would be
priceless that's garyvee become garyvee
and they just have a phone call
all that happens all that garyvee's
content is life it's just
him existing being gary vaynerchuk and
him having a man
with a lens pointed at him all the time
probably probably quite a low effort
life if you're just doing what you do
normally
oh hugely but there's a as much as i
don't like gary vaynerchuk and i'm
certain that he's going to die young
because he doesn't sleep enough
like he uh which like tell me that's not
the truth by the way no he he looks
so tired like he's just slightly [ __ ]
so
because i i've never seen any of his
content before until you asked about the
other day
george asked about him and um he just
happened to be live and i quickly went
onto the live and he sat there on
skype just like oh really
i was just like man this guy needs to go
and get some sleep
25 000 into 300 million
so i don't even care i don't even care
um
but yeah so like gary vaynerchuk i
didn't realize this but all of his books
he just sits in a room with a ghost
writer for like
a day and just talks at him then the
ghost writer goes away with 10 hours of
gary vaynerchuk recording and converts
it into a book books
that's impressive i've got a copy of um
jab jab jab right hook down there uh but
no i haven't read it i've read i think
it's called crush it
which was quite it's quite tough read
why uh like it's good but it's just it
is just a bit
like just do loads of stuff
on the internet for a very long time and
eventually you'll like earn an alright
living from it
so something that i would pay to
subscribe to is johnny watson book
reviews because johnny's threshold
for what is a useful book is so high
that it's fun so like the his review of
the
grant cardone 10x rule he's gonna spit
out his drink what was that
i haven't heard this one it's just
see have you ever read the 10x rule by
grant cardone no
it's basically just like 10x
everything that you think about so if
you think about something like
10x's what's that the whole thing of
like well
precisely this whole thing of like
taking
taking massive action i no one's ever
been able to explain how that's distinct
from
just completing a task
like why is that why is that any
different is it just that it's a big
important task
therefore the action's massive
yeah weird like we're already doing
action yeah everyone's already
do the action tasks all day so it's just
a case of picking the right ones to do
but everyone knows that already
it's just because it makes you feel
hardcore and yeah grinding
entrepreneur isn't it content about it
when you've got
when you've got an american that does
that they come out like someone like
grant cardone but if it was someone from
the uk
that was doing that they'd come out like
who's that
broomy real estate trader yeah i was
just thinking that the property guy
yeah it was on um mike when it's show
sam something some your leads some your
leads
yeah some of your leads like all right
home samuel leeds
yeah that's it i'm gonna buy some
property today
that's it that's a very good accent
that's the equivalent
i've never i see him pop up on youtube
quite a bit i always assume that it's
because yourself watches him
secretly it's a bit of a secret yeah
he's he's good
he's he's a bit oh you'd hate his
accounting knowledge though his
accounting advice
sometimes well that's it and he just
gives accounting advice
all right and it's very like awesome i
think if you're
not ironically if you're not a chartered
accountant you can just give accounting
advice and there's no recourse like
who's gonna
what's what's gonna happen same with
medical advice like there's no
there's no medical body to be struck off
from if you're just
unless you're actually qualified to give
the advice it's a free-for-all
so anybody can give the advice online
apart from the people who are qualified
to
and they're all like oh i'm not i'm not
oh i'm not getting involved in this
[ __ ] don't do without me it's not
i am not your accountant
it's definitely a lesson in there that
it should be switched and you should be
allowed to give
medical advice online just that taking
advice online is a
like nightmare yeah like what you know
someone's giving advice online like
what's their agenda very fraught
very fraught but you've both seen
just on the ground cardone you've both
seen the jordan belford gran cardone
interview
yeah if anyone's got like 90 minutes
free and thinks like i'd like to watch a
bit of youtube
it's just some of the most like awkward
uncomfortable
two fairly big names um
just you just sat there like someone was
going
i thought you really get angry grant
came out of that really badly
like jordan jordan's supposed to be this
jordan has lived the life
that grant is pretending to live like
this big dick
high money status all the birds all the
drugs this sort of thing
um and grant just kept trying to one-up
him
and to his credit jordan just played the
host role
he was like yeah oh okay okay okay like
but
try and ask a question try and time down
to a point and then like you say grant
i can kind of see reflecting on that
interview i can now
guess what the book's about because it's
it's
very substanceless yeah have you seen
those like
those fake um martial arts masters that
do like the touch of
death and then like five people fall
down on the other side of the room
it's it's kind of a little bit like that
and then putting him in a room with
wolf of wall street was like when you
see those guys go in the ring with the
ufc fighter
and they just get their face caved in
there's a huge
cult following behind these people
because even the students of them it's
not like they're paid to believe it but
they really buy into the whole thing
like oh this is the guru that's the
master and they
and then they defend him from and if
there is a fight they go it's because of
the bad energy in the room and it
disrupted the like conduction of the
waves and he does like 10x 10x
conferences
that are huge that are done in stadiums
in the us he fills like
football stadiums of people and it's a
big like
i think he had floyd mayweather there
yeah last time
yeah i've seen him go go on stage with
him yeah but it's just when jordan asks
him about like
how does like cardone capital work and
he just doesn't really answer the
question
or like how do you sell and he just
doesn't also doesn't really understand
and then
grant just accuse him of accuses him of
being on drugs and that's just the thing
that he does then
like oh well you were you were on drugs
so obviously it worked for you
has had a film made about him
and like a plate like a boeing plane
that someone's just painted
like dark green
it is oh man i don't know it's weird
right because these people
unless someone brings them down to earth
they're just going to
be able to continue
floating through life presuming that
everything's fine
and maybe everything is fine maybe maybe
grant cardone isn't doing anything wrong
but it kind of feels like
he's a bit of a dick it's hard to say
isn't it it's hard to say whether any
company is or isn't doing anything wrong
because people have strong a bit like on
amazon for example people have
opinions that amazon are doing things
that are wrong like they under under
price things with like their white label
products and all that sort of stuff
so yeah like the and the people who are
losing with amazon are not the consumers
that it's more the the other suppliers
with grant cardone i think the people
who are losing based on
mike winner's experiment chris you spoke
to didn't you on on the podcast a while
ago yes
um he he just goes and buys all these
like make money online schemes
and just sees if they work and it's like
if someone has made a lot of money from
the program great you know there's proof
of concept but
if not and they're just being ascended
through this pyramid scheme because
there's
the stooges in the stadiums as well like
he employs people to
but well this isn't just for legal
reasons this isn't necessarily grant
cardone this is the person who
was in the entrepreneur yeah yeah
yeah um had stooges in the audience
um being like yeah i bought this and
it's been great and i'll buy it too
and yeah me too and they're all stood
like in
spread around the audience very clever
it's mental
i'm sure though that he must have
thousands of people who are
happy and that's like the balance isn't
it it's hard to
so mike hasn't found that this is the
kind of
uh canary in the coal mine test mike
hasn't found a single person
who's made money from grant's course who
isn't a reseller of grant's course
the only people he's found that make
money from it are people selling the
course
on how to make money from it right
which is is a pyramid scheme
yeah avon is avon a pyramid scheme
i think that all these things are gray
areas and
quite hard to because it there was there
was that guy who that documentary called
betting on zero
yes that guy was convinced that
herbalife is a pyramid scheme so he just
shorted it with his hedge fund
and just held a huge short position so
you know that that guy
what's his name what was the guy's name
that did i'm gonna have to get it up i
can't remember
he's made the most money the best
trade in history this year
is it on wall street bets no it's not
bill ackman
okay so right yeah bill ackman
um this year decided that he was going
to take out a very
specific type of um
insurance against there it is 2.6
billion
big short so it's called like the new
big short basically
hedge fund chief bets on stock market
recovery after profiting from
coronavirus sell-off
in late february bill ackman began
worrying about the approaching
coronavirus pandemic
he was concerned that he contemplated
selling all the holdings of the ingress
investment group he founded almost two
decades ago instead working from his
study from home
mr ackman made a series of trades
designed to hedge persing square's
portfolio
that is to protect it in the event of a
market sell-off within a month
the trade had returned 2.6
billion dollars of profits captivating
the hedge fund world
and thrusting one of its most
controversial stars back in the
limelight
uh what was the size of the trade uh i'm
trying to see it here it doesn't really
seem to have god
like turning up to your desk and being
like oh i'm a bit worried about this
impending
coronavirus pandemic so i should maybe
hedge my portfolio against it yeah
unbelievable unbelievable
uh and the guy that was the
person featured in the big short
yeah that christian bale played um it's
basically being compared to his trade
except for the fact that
yes michael michael someone um except
for the fact that bill ackman did his in
a month
so hold on so he he predicted the
coronavirus and so
put on a short position no he just saw
the coronavirus in early february
and predicted that the impact of the
coronavirus would be bigger than most
people were going to expect than
correct don't we all wish we'd shorted
in february
and then gone long tesla in february
because it's four times the
stock price now it's insane
that's why these people are billionaires
isn't it why is that why not right
you you had a an interesting insight you
said kind of like market sentiments
become decoupled from value
yeah exactly that that you've got
companies like
tesla that have almost become separate
they've become completely
decoupled from the stock price it's no
longer about the valuation of the
company
it's just like well screw it because the
whole market is completely irrational
now
the index is just unpredictable with
like
more and more people are becoming yolo
traders and sentiment is now just
becoming the like
i'm sorry at home i'm wound up i'm just
gonna start trading stuff like here's
elon just tweeting
illegal stuff about his stock prices and
oh he's on
joe rogan here he is smoking a joint
like he's cool okay
yeah didn't he tweet something saying
like tesla's under
underpriced at the moment stock price
too high i am too high
that was it oh christ
like that but he got taken off the board
right because of that tweet no
before that tweet but but surely is that
not still some kind of like
market rigging or like he's free now
because if he's off the board he can say
what he wants but people still see him
as the the
the head fairly major shareholder in it
though
surely he must own someone that knows
good percentage tell us how it works
please in the comments below
um i imagine elon knows how it works
elon does know how it works
but then also i don't think that he
gives one [ __ ]
i don't think he cares he's just sold
all his possessions because they're an
attack vector
i know that's brilliant isn't it i think
that's brilliant
he's gone full alex when rogan asked him
that he was like
they're on a tech vector like that is a
man that's just on a different
he's in a different world to everybody
else on a separate level like i have to
have a tesla
for obvious reasons for testing that
that's why
i'm renting on aliens and living in a
simulation and stuff i'm like
do you know what he's probably thought
about it he's done the work hasn't he
there's an interview with him where he's
like he talks about how he's like
frustrated
that he will probably he probably won't
be alive when we by the time we get to
mars
it's crazy it's crazy to have such a
so many levels of imazo's hierarchy
sorted that the thing you think about on
a daily basis
is like building roads under the
surface of the earth to sort out
congestion and getting the human race to
mars
there's a video that's pretty cool for
if people want to watch it where him and
jay
leno get in a prototype of the cyber
truck
have you seen this i don't know so they
in la
elon musk turns up outside with a cyber
truck jay leno's
it's like jay leno's car garage thing he
it's
kind of like top gear but on youtube
it's pretty good
um and then they take one of the
tunnels like boring company tunnels
for a mile in the cyber truck and then
it like they just start in the middle of
some car park and then arrive
in whatever it is like spacex's uh
offices essentially take this huge
elevator up by like
500 feet when they get to the end of the
tunnel and is that real that tunnel
yes right well i mean what do you mean
i didn't know it actually built any like
there is a legit tunnel
actual which is a couple of maybe a mile
long or a couple of miles long
right under la you drive in on one end
and get an
elevator a car elevator up at the other
end
and it actually happens and it fits a
cyber truck in
to get the whatever planning permission
you need to
borrow you don't apparently you don't
need any because it's not it's
underground isn't it
it's not owned by anyone but it's like
how far underground do you need to be
where well that's the question
yeah like do you own the ground under
your house
or not i'm sure again someone will
answer this question i think that
the big thing here is it's the same as
everything that happens when technology
moves as quick as it does
it outstrips the ability to litigate
against it
it's like until someone had the ability
privately to build a tunnel under la
there didn't need to be any laws about
it it was the same as in new york
facebook but in manhattan they were
selling the
air space so they were selling the
um square feet edge
directly above properties and that was
like the building
in manhattan creates a law around it
well like
facebook and google and all these
companies that are now like in senate
and when zuckerberg was a couple of
years
last year or whatever i guess yeah like
this is them trying to catch up and then
you've got all these like fuddy-duddy
senate members that are like so if i'm
using the facebook
it was i think something for the most
you know um bazos a question i can't
remember what it was
i just like this guy asks jeff bezos a
question
that he's kind of put like a morning of
thought into it
you think this man really really
understands the subject you're asking
him about
and you're hoping to like duck and dive
and catch him out it's just not gonna
work is it
like what let's just not bother with any
of this because when you've got
like tim cook from apple jeff bezos
zuk and like whoever they have from
google like
who's gonna win do you know do you know
when you watch
a toddler play fighting with his dad
on the bed and the dad's on his the
dad's on his knees as well and he's like
got his hands up kind of like this
pretending and the toddler's like
and then the dad kind of oh
yeah it falls over that's exactly what
it was like
there's a new sam harris i've been
really really impressed with this
podcast recently
the can we pull back from the brink and
tons of people that i
sent it to went and listened to it and
really enjoyed it um there's another one
which is significantly more dark
but it's about the current internet uh
epidemic
the world's worst epidemic about child
pornography online
and basically he uh he brings up this
senate meeting where he's talking about
just how far
lawmakers are behind the technology and
what they need to be able to do
and he refers to it he says you've got
this bunch of geezers
up there at the top trying to
cross-examine some of the smartest
people on the planet when they can't
even unlock their iphones
oh my god i like
it so good isn't it i can imagine him
saying it as well
it's amazing it's so good
[ __ ] geezers remember
we saw some geezers actual geezers
it was an eggy very yucky eggy bread
very cold if you're funny because if you
consider
going to iceland it's very sulfury
everything's just
quite sulfury isn't it smells of egg the
water in the showers smell of egg
and everything's extremely expensive and
extremely cold
it's when you start in it like having to
crouch in an eggy shower
nursing your meningitis and yeah and
your
dog and your wallet
do you want it yeah one second
went to the corner shop the cheapest
thing to buy was lucky charms and a full
domino's pizza and that's all you can
eat first or you go to like the local
mexican restaurant
and have to like take out a payday loan
to get
to get a side but then you have some
salty licorice in a big packet and it's
all okay
um perhaps ski a yogurt man it's so good
isn't it
i have you tried that lindell's no i've
not looked good though
they're too small for me chris that's
the main objection do they do them in
larger tubs
uh they do not know however allah has
started to do
a an equivalent basically which is again
another sort of 20
larger but dude the macros on it there
is some
wizardry going on there or we're going
to find out in two years time that
they've done a vw and just been lying
about the emissions
did they have the quest i think quest
like
misstated the calories on the on quest
bars for a while or something
because of net carbs or fiber or
something like that
um but yeah there's a back door where
you can actually
revert the carbs of
you can fill in a form and you get to
claim all the calories back
you can submit it to when you go out for
dinner you're like okay
you know does this apply um sorry you
know how does it run out
yeah it was a technicality on it on the
like oligosaccharides or something
yeah actually this is only carb if you
do this but then if you make one little
break on the molecule then it
it's very naughty yeah and everyone
everybody meanwhile
everyone's gaining weight because of
quest bars
if anyone's trucking is that precise
like because the thing about trucking is
it's all just arbitrary anyway as long
as we're
waiting which is amazing so there's a
there's a gym
that i think is techno gem plates where
i was looking at the calibration
it's like 20 or something or 10
and so you're like well that could be
200 kilos on the bar and it could be
anything from 180 to 220.
yeah it's fine when you like sub 100
isn't it
you know it's nothing because yeah but
as soon as you start getting up to some
big numbers it's like someone's gonna
have a real accident here if you're not
because there was always the case where
like
you you'd go to a different gym and
you'd either hit
mod pbs or you would be like oh my god
i'm really struggling today like
on the cable stuff where like in one gym
it says 30
and then another gym comes 30 and it's
like immovable and like surely the the
30 it doesn't mean anything it's just an
arbitrary
it's just a relative measure it's only
useful to the people that go to that gym
yeah it's just a way for you to anchor
how difficult that set's going to be
oh
um but gold star's a perfect example of
that man like when you've got weights
that are older than some of the people
that are lifting them
and they're older than time actual
chunks of matter
missing from them it's like you're
always going to feel like you're able to
lift more in that gym
because a 50 is like a 35.
it's very clever it it's consumer
lock-in it's the same way that one
password or last pass like
keep you locked into their system
because there's no export feature so you
can't then export your
training data outside of that gym
because you're like well it's all just
relatively profitable
i love that that's obviously a big issue
for you isn't it a big
like if someone's described like
describe your top five
so chris had an absolute um
heinous situation with this i tweeted
one password about this
because i'm not gonna make any kind of
causative claims but
chris had one password cancelled his
membership
and then the next day what happened
you google must have some sort of search
function
where they look for phishing sites and
forums
that are publishing usernames and
passwords
that you that tie in with what you have
canceled
last one password and it was that night
like within hours i got a warning that
88 of my passwords
were now visible online and i'm like
does
it just what just from chrome so google
gives you a warning so as you go to auto
fill stuff in
it pops up and says this many of your
passwords are this
which 88 passwords that you need to go
and change manually
is a task that took weeks do they tell
you which ones
yes yes yes they do right okay yeah well
otherwise how would you know
well i don't know because i feel like
it's not really google's responsibility
i know i couldn't believe that for them
to provide that kind of service
for free for no reason because one
password's gone oh well
just [ __ ] people are launching that
apple watch tower or something yeah
watchtower
maybe that's what last round look at the
top with a with a telescope
but yeah that is
that only has three special characters
in it and sent me this thing recently
about the
cause is apple valued at a trillion
dollars
i don't know i wouldn't be surprised
let me see if i can i can find this
while you're finding it here we go and
i've got it i've got it so in terms of
in terms of comprehending a trillion
compared to a million
so a million seconds is 11 days
we've heard this before a million
seconds is 11 days
a trillion seconds is 36 000 years
not really just because i think there
was a time this might be wrong
but i think there was a time where apple
had like
a trillion of cash or something is that
right
really they had more cash than like the
federal reserve yeah something like that
maybe that's wrong maybe it's not so if
someone
if someone had just said to tim listen
mate
come on mate i give him just yeah
transfer us
what is the quid what's your thoughts
on people's criticisms about bezos
becoming the first trillionaire
yeah so apple according to forbes
as of july the 9th valued at 1.6
trillion
which is nearly as much as what bezos is
going to be worth in a year or two's
time
he's going to thought he's going to be
the world's first trillionaire
i mean that well as we've just discussed
is
mental but i think i don't know
i think a lot of people don't like the
fact that one person holds so much
wealth
and then there's like a ton of
criticisms about like jack dorsey gave
away
i think like 30 percent of his shares
or 30 of his net worth or something
to charities so they're basically
accusing him of not doing enough
philanthropy
i think he does quite a bit of
philanthropy basis yeah
there is a point when you've got that
much net worth that you can give away
such a high percentage and it has no
material impact on your
quality of life like there's anyone like
a house you can get yeah
yeah on that netflix explain thing they
talk about i used to think it is they
talk about billionaires
and how like once you cross across a
certain wealth threshold
the you gain so much more wealth from
the wealth itself
that it becomes out of control just like
once interested or whatever like it i
think something like it was hard
it's it's very hard for 100 million to
not become 110 million
which is is ridiculous isn't it so then
you may think that you've got a billion
to not turn that into 1.5 billion
over time because of just percentages
and how things work have you heard of
that film
where you someone has like 10 million
pounds or something and they have to
spend it by
in 24 hours no no and
like he actually has a really hard time
trying to do it because of loads of like
red tape and um people not trusting it
and all this stuff and like the
challenge is that he has to
you have to spend it by the end of the
day you never think that you'll just run
into like
bureaucracy as there's the reason why
you can't spend
months i promise this is all right like
you can't go to the bank and withdraw
any more than like a really silly amount
of cash and
and it's just i think it would be
because what would you say is liquidity
you couldn't get it in physical cash so
you'd have to pay for everything and
you'd reach all kinds of like fraud
limits and
be on the phone at the bank constantly
cinema pick and mix
that's what you've got that's really
expensive yeah
it is not sell it on no not arbitrage
you need to get rid of the money
i see you've just got to spend it yeah
so your strategy chris is
so i think you'd have to go across the
cinemas
in the uk and buy it i am cinema yeah
so i would use i'd use the initial
million to employ as many people as i
could for the day yes
and get them to go around all the
cinemas in the uk and buy all of the
mix yes and maybe you'd have to do all
of it but immediately you run into an
operational problem which is
employing that many people that quickly
making sure that they are
you know operating towards a y structure
it's not even that
it's not even that it's like how do you
ensure that like keith in glasgow
is doing what you asked them to do
because it means
commission but then how do you how do
you police the commission
exactly oh that's incredible you know
that there was no one born
with the name keith in 2019.
was it keith i thought it was nigel in
20 2016.
2018. yeah wow nobody are a dying breed
man
it's not a very baby name oh little
keith
you grow into that name don't you you
become a keith we
we had a guy who became a class and
he was not he was always known as big
keith and he was just a man
all the time it feels like you've got to
be at least 40 before you can
justify being called keith in my head
there's someone called keith listening
who's 22
and dress is really cool and he's like
[ __ ]
i tell you um can you imagine how few
currents there's going to be oh my god
did you see that a bunch of karen's went
on this morning to complain
and so someone made a meme of it that
said this is the most current thing that
you could do
it's the level of like the levels that
goes to
and it's the it's i wonder whether
because i feel like you would think
about that wouldn't you before you went
on
you'd be like what are we being accused
of here what's the
what's the essence of the problem here
it's it's the
and then is this helping or hindering
ah how would you deal with it if your
name was karen
i think you just like don't take it
seriously yeah
you know you know i don't presumably
they're not encountering any kind of
real issues from it it's just a bit of
internet
video guy dean's mum is karen does she
mind
no so that i think that upgrade like if
you're like oh yeah i'm called karen
it's quite funny
like like own it really live it yeah but
you're kind of hand struck if you're 40
and you're called karen it i mean you're
changing your names
i mean here's one way to look at it
because obviously as someone who's just
lost one of the most important
tendons in his body he's been reading a
fair bit of stoicism
um turn that around
if it was ryan holiday that was looking
at it he would say that's great
everyone's got incredibly low
expectations of you much easier to beat
them
yeah nice precisely what he would say if
your name's karen
you now don't have to be anywhere near
as polite or impressive to be polite and
impressive
that you just need to not be a [ __ ] and
you're already miles above what everyone
is
expecting of you well if you just
continue as you were
that's immediately held in higher regard
fantastic low expectations are an
advantage one i thought dexter was your
microphone there
i thought you were just talking into his
head as the microphone no no he's not
he's just looking wistfully forward
um has anyone watched dark on netflix
so since i saw you talking about it i've
tried and i'm
really struggling oh johnny please i'm
persist
oh please do and anyone anyone that's
listening so i
am very much of the same mindset i think
more of youssif but oh no actually you
like
subtitles right yeah okay well i
you have subtitles and everything don't
you you choose you elect subtitles
you've opted in for subtitles haven't
you
i prefer to watch the is it is it german
yes i prefer to watch the german because
the dub the voice service it's the
dubbing it just loses
all of the kind of because it's like a
really tense like well-lit and it's like
hey
what are you doing over there
no so i i tried to i watched the first
episode overdubbed
and then me and my housemate will like
right we'll watch the second one
subtitled which is obviously very
effortful
like you're basically reading books for
hours
you watch the dub program but with
subtitles on no so i
watched no subtitles english overdubs
on the first episode of dark couldn't
get away with it just
exactly as you said like all the tense
moments were destroyed it just sucks
and then episode two went with subtitles
we're now on the final episode of season
two
and dude it's like it's so
good hold on hold on can't are you
saying
that there's an option to switch off the
dubbing
english dubbing yeah i just presume that
was like pre-loaded
now you can you can switch to it to
original audio oh my god
pretty good closed captions you want to
go audio and audio and captions
turn off go to like the original audio
and you want english not closed captions
uh subtitles because closed caption
subtitles must be for people that are
like hard of hearing
and that's when they describe like
russell leaves the door yeah yeah
exactly
it's like dramatic dramatic music and
then
when it when the uh intro music plays it
tells you it's like um ellie goulding
stars and stripes
as the me it's like what hang on if i
can't hear that i have no reference for
what that means
short sharp beats i've definitely had it
watched something before with that just
on and didn't realize that's what
it was and i was like this program is
really weird like yeah it's like a
narrator that's talking about really
like mundane stuff
dude dark oh man if you can switch it
over
because that that's the only thing i
struggle with it's just the
total mismatch yeah completely handled
the the total mismatch
mismatch of like this what should be the
sort of mood of the scene
and the dubbing it must be it's just
though
it turns it into like a parody of the of
the same species
it just totally takes you out of the
moment right yeah completely
imagine if you're a voice actor there
might be some listening like if you're
someone who has to do this job like the
actors that are there
get to be in the scene they've been on
set all day they're talking to the
person they can see that and then
you get right jonathan it's your turn
now mate we've got uh about
about 15 minutes to get this scene
nailed then jonathan has to
what watch it on tv was seeing the
script whilst matching his voice to
someone who's not saying those words is
other language noise
which relates to the words he's saying
because like the intonation's different
in different
cultures isn't it so like i think we
go like in especially northern think we
go up at the end of sentences yeah
australians are big on that upward
inflection i love it everything's a
question if you're australian going up
at the end of sentences
yeah yeah it's um but yeah i was super
super impressed with dark anyway that
needs something to watch on tv i uh
i highly recommend that wasn't impressed
by the business of drugs
which i thought i would be yeah i've
started i watched again
i just pied it just watched one episode
and i was just like was that the german
one of the
got the kids that set up a dark web
thing
no no it's like a documentary series on
netflix okay
not impressed you know one of the things
that i couldn't i actually re-round
re-round and watch like three times was
the this lady's like a cia agent right
yes yeah and they keep a scene in where
she's getting into the back of this like
military plane
and nearly like clearly you know when
you like go to step up on something high
and you like go for the initial push off
and it isn't quite enough and you have
to come back down again and do it again
that like nearly happens to her and she
has to like press herself
off of off our own leg and then goes and
has this really serious conversation
with like uh
someone in about drugs and they keep it
in
i just think it's a bit harsh it just
doesn't it doesn't
paint her in a very like this is a very
serious situation and she's like
like someone needs to make a compilation
of all those little you know like
where you you try and pick up the glass
and you miss your mouth or you can
trip a little bit on the page like reach
a door or something behind you
just grasping at the air for ages the
worst the worst one
is thinking that there isn't a step
there going downstairs
oh god there's one more left yeah and if
for some reason it really hits you hard
doesn't it
the same as all the other steps if you
pick up a glass and you think it's full
and it's not and you go
which is funny right because the
tolerance that you've got shouldn't be
so
fine like a kilo or half a kilo of
liquid
makes the difference between you slowly
bringing it to your face or throwing it
at the ceilings
it's amazing like we're so calibrated
with little stuff like that we don't
even
realize yeah you need to speak to techno
jim that's that's perhaps a solution
that they could go with
you start with me a lot when when i was
going to see the clients as
an auditor because you'd always be in a
different building you'd always be
dealing with different
different like in office environments
and i would always
always be a time it probably happened
once a month where i'd go into like in a
person's office
open the door and use too much force and
it's like
bang off the thing and you're like oh
there's no
way to not look like i think you have to
just do that
just hands on hips so i am here now yeah
here i am
um look seth you've got to get off it's
your mom's birthday
it is so happy birthday mother scobe um
i think this is uh this is probably
going to go out on thursday which will
be the day after
i have my uh operation so hopefully i'm
uh i'm absolutely fine
i said on the intro to an episode the
other day that i'm gonna try my best
to continue with a fairly regular
publishing schedule
reason being that like you just need to
do something like the alternative
is having no reason to get up having no
reason to kind of like transcend your
discomfort
there was that episode i did with kamal
ravikamp where he lost
almost all of the blood out of his body
and was able to take himself off
yeah he took himself off opiates because
he wanted to read the manuscript with
enough
like fidelity that he could tell where
the punctuation was right and wrong
and it's like if you have a strong
enough reason to kind of transcend
anything that's
uncomfortable it'll be fine and you know
this is a
a pretty good version for me so yeah
hopefully um
we will be not too disrupted
when it comes to the recording schedule
and the publishing schedule and that
will help to hold me accountable which
will be
which would be nice
presumably it's kind of one of the only
things you can do
post surgery i need to be horizontal
third it's just
brilliant that was mental when i saw
this the story description of it
yeah it was all sort of like within
expectation like the recovery times and
all sorts of things but that
that point i was just like 50 minutes
with your legos out of every 60 for two
weeks
is that because it's just naturally
can't not load bearish
it's to get the swelling down need to
get
need to get foot up get
fluid out do they i imagine the surgery
is just like tying a big
like a bow double knot in it sutured
sutured together with semi-dissolvable
sutures oh well
dissolvable sutures that take three
months so so clever isn't it
yeah it's pretty it's pretty fun
medicine and doctors and stuff
i know could you ever go yousef if i
just said
get get a kitchen knife out could you
have a crack
it's kind of like asking johnny to like
go into a
spanish um construction company
no like financial institution okay
really complex
like a spanish hedge fund and just being
like can you just like
run the accounts and then go well i can
have a crack at it
i know i know mostly where everything is
but the specifics are going to be
i'd i'd buck you i'd back you as well
i don't think you'd do anything wrong
well i made it worse is this this
surgery
or just doing like just one mile
operation
just being a single theater team just me
there's loads of films where they do it
and i feel like it would be really a
responsibility yeah but when they get a
bit of snow
and they'll like they'll have a knife
like remove a bullet and all that sort
of stuff just if someone who's not even
a doctor can remove a bullet from
themselves with like a
a mirror and a
yeah well just like watching movies
throughout 2010 2020 has taught me that
any wound just needs cauterizing
like porterize it doesn't matter how bad
it is yeah just just
cauterize it that's it the thing i
always wonder is
in films where the bullets gone all the
way through no one ever seems that
worried
i was like surely like that means it's
done loads of damage
but the exit wounds gonna be huge
massive
but as long as you like put a bandage on
then it's like it's honestly it's like
straight through
nothing to worry about hang on no that
there'd be nothing to worry about if it
hadn't hit me
it means something to worry about
because someone just shot at you
yeah less less to worry about
[Laughter]
unbelievable the question of like do you
take the knife out or do you leave it in
do you turn up to a e with a knife
sticking out of you like do you leave
the bullet in
surely you leave it in it's i think it
depends
on a lot of things
to be honest i wouldn't want to make
that call it's not it's not a plug it's
not a drain plug is it
well that that that's what you want to
be careful of and also if there's a
bullet in it's like
has it introduced more infection than it
or like is it going to cause more trauma
by removing it if it's a serrated
knife by removing it are you going to
cause more damage
but then it's like well okay how do you
get it out anyway then
someone's going to have to take it out
aren't they at some point yeah
unless you just made the right decision
that's that you'd have if you left a
knife in your shoulder for the rest of
time you'd have somewhere to hang stuff
wouldn't you
it would be the sort of thing where
you'd like you'd catch it on something
it would come out your door
yeah leaving
you have to have the conversation i had
a knife my shoulder was still there
that's what they
have to pay for the jumper even though
he didn't want it all that sort of stuff
i would leave i think i would leave it
in based on my believe it in absolute
zero understanding of any of this i feel
like that's
my knee-jerk response would be better in
the note
well no initially far better out than in
but once it's in it feels like it'd be
better in the now it's fine
that's the only thing that you think
should stay in as well isn't it
everything else in life is just a series
of
it out buildups to you being able to get
something out of you
which is the thing because it's like
food and water that's nice to go in it's
also i'm sure there was a podcast where
we talked about this
yeah it's just me johnny yeah it was it
was johnny's philosophy on like things
going in your body versus things going
coming out of your body well the idea
that everything coming out feels nice
oh yeah that's it it's very very little
suppose apart from a cough but that's
not really coming out of you is it
per se coming out of you
yours are nice anyway
was like things going in a nice and then
we then we
clarified that most things could be put
in
if with someone who had like the right
tools frame of mind skills
and motivation there's ways you could
put things into people
if you really applied yourself to it and
only some of the things are nice
that's true it's easier the the barrier
for what is nice is easier for going out
than in isn't it
there's a select number of things going
in that are nice but
most of the things going out are nice
yeah yeah
i'm glad that we've i'm glad that we've
managed to uh better outline it better
better out than in except
unless it's a knife in your shoulder uh
look gentlemen thank you very much
propane fitness dot com slash modern
wisdom
and propane fitness dot com slash
calculator if you want macros all will
be linked in the show notes below if
you're a pt who wants to
take your game to the online level then
speak to them they're
available and it's the seven steps to
make a business in
a day or something basically just tells
you
everything that you would need to know
for free
including actually get a knife out of
your shoulder the third thing
the third thing that we talk about no
one can ever believe
what an opening league that third thing
johnny may i can't believe
you talk about that propanefitness.com
modern wisdom go and see it gentlemen
thank you very much i will see you once
i have two achilles again
bye
[Music]